- What's been
the hardest lesson
for you to learn in your life?
- [Gary] That
I can't do everything.
- What are things you would love
to be doing that
you're not doing?
- [Gary] Nothing.
- You would rather
be doing nothing?
- [Gary] Nothing.
- Or there is nothing--
- No, no, correct.
There is nothing,
I'm in full control of my life.
If there's something
I want to do
then I can go do it.
We make our beds.
So, I sleep in it.
- What do you think
about your employees?
Do you think they all
share the same ideology
that you do
about doing everything
that it is they
want to be doing?
- [Gary] Absolutely not.
- Why do you think that is?
- Because I think people
are wired differently
and I think I have to,
I don't even want,
all I want to do was
react to what they want
and how they aspire to be or
what they're interested in.
I have no interest
in them being like me
or not being like me.
I'm in the reaction business.
And so, I just think
people are hardwired.
I don't think everybody was
as lucky to have a mother
that told them
they could do anything
and actually make
them believe it.
And that's unfortunate
and I hope through
example and content
I'm able to inspire that but
I think practicality
is grossly underrated
and for all my sizzle,
I'm obsessed with the steak.
(light music)